so you vote for a political party and
you have no right to expect they'll do
everything you want or that their views
will be exactly the same as yours you
may send them money and loyally support
them but of course there's going to be
some Divergence between what you want
them to do and what they actually end up
doing but for a party just weeks after
taking office in this case Republicans
in the house to flip 180 degrees on two
of the biggest Topics in American Life
that's kind of a middle finger right in
your face isn't it here are a couple of
examples
the new chairman of the house Foreign
Affairs committee Michael McCall of
Texas just announced on CNN over the
weekend that any Republican who opposes
sending billions more to Ukraine needs
to be quote educated on why the borders
in Ukraine matter a whole lot more than
our borders here watch
a lot of members of your conference
fellow Republicans they want to stop
giving money to Ukraine
should Ukraine be worried that the money
is going to stop coming from the U.S no
no I think there's enough support on
both sides of the aisle majority in the
the Democratic party majority in the
Republican the National Security
chairman like myself support this we we
have to educate our members I don't
think they quite understand what is at
stake
so it was just right before the last
election in November that Michael McCall
that guy was saying no we really should
audit all these billions we've sent to
zielinski and his wife and Ukraine's we
have no idea where the money went and we
should know before we send more now he's
just saying no the only group in America
doesn't need to worry you you have to
worry you can't afford eggs but
zielinski and his wife don't have to
worry because we're never going to stop
sending them billions of dollars then he
went on to demand the Biden
Administration sent M1 tanks to Ukraine
because that's the part not to our
border of his State over which over 7
million people have come in the last
years no tanks on our border but tanks
for Ukraine's border they don't have to
worry and Lindsey Graham of course
agrees
Lindsey Graham got completely unhinged
visiting his real constituents in Kiev
over the weekend watch this
all three of us Republicans and
Democrats
share the same goal
number two
for Ukraine to drive the Russians out of
Ukraine to achieve that goal the Ukraine
military needs tanks
is
I'm tired of the show surrounding who's
going to send tanks and when they're
going to send them
of course Germany could pay for Europe
could pay for it Ukraine is in Europe
but there's Lindsey Graham standing
between the two most left-wing members
of the United States Senate demanding
that you pay for it after a full year
they lied to you for a year and told you
where Ukraine was winning now they're
conceding Ukraine is losing and you have
to double your commitment to Ukraine wow
they really don't care about you do they
at all and just to underscore how little
they care a few days ago the new
chairman of the house Financial Services
committee
a republican from North Carolina called
Patrick McHenry announced that one of
the biggest problems with American
Finance today
the thing he's worried most about
is that too many white men work in
banking
this fact this overabundance of male
whiteness
is apparently pressing emergency
so Congressman McHenry directed all six
of the financial services subcommittees
to get to work fighting whiteness the
subcommittee on housing and insurance
for example will focus on quote policies
to continue to strengthen diversity and
inclusion in the Housing Industry
how about just housing for American
citizens no it's got to be race-based
according to Congressman McHenry in the
case of the subcommittee in oversight
diversity and conclusion inclusion were
the only specific oversight focuses that
were listed
now what is this we asked we called
around Capitol Hill and one person with
knowledge of the decision-making told us
that Congressman Henry is doing this
because he does not want to upset Maxine
Waters that would be the ranking
Democrat on the committee and a person
with a long history of making hateful
and violent statements about white
people so Maxine Waters is an out of the
closet racist she's an accomplished
hater
but Congressman Patrick McHenry of North
Carolina is anxious to placate her
not you her Maxine Waters now why why is
he so anxious to make Maxine Waters
happy we reach out to Congressman
mchenry's office today invite him on the
show to explain
he of course declined that offer is
always open
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight